blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
welcome everybody so
i i'm going to talk today about the
biden putin summit that took place
yesterday in geneva switzerland we're
going to start with
uh vladimir putin's press conference
momentarily later i want to talk about
donald trump's analysis
if you can use that term which you
really shouldn't uh trump's analysis on
fox news of the summit and i i
hate that i even have to do this but i
want to just remind everybody
i don't want war with russia uh the
united states
also does bad things um
etc and every time i talk about this
and i just point out the way i see
vladimir putin and russian government
i get all sorts of emails from people
saying david you're falling for this and
you're falling for that and you should
have this other opinion like this person
or that
i'm not those people so if you want only
to listen to someone with
that opinion go to a different show this
is my view and my view is not that i
want war with russia
my view is not that putin is uniquely
bad
but there are some really interesting
and unique characteristics of how
vladimir putin handle handles himself
with media and how how he runs his
government
that i think are worthy of some
discussion so yesterday joe biden and
vladimir putin had a meeting it was more
than three hours long
the american right wing was hoping that
joe biden would embarrass himself and be
unable to speak he'd
be in a fit of acute dementia pooping
his pants or whatever
that didn't happen at the same time
there were some on the left
that often play koi with putin who
were hoping that biden would be exposed
in this summit
as some kind of neocon warhawk who would
threaten
putin and go completely crazy and that
also didn't happen and it was mostly
unremarkable
in that it was normal diplomacy with a
normal president and a normal secretary
of state
the four years of trump were everything
as power
games and uh often just
placating authoritarian leaders around
the world
uh people forgot sort of how diplomacy
works and it's kind of boring
biden goes in with the list of
priorities that he wants to mention and
then the secretary of state and
foreign minister whatever the equivalent
position is called in russia
they have sort of second tier things on
their list that they talk about and it's
a long
and in some colloquial sense boring
process of
diplomacy but the most interesting part
for me
was actually the press conference that
happened after the event
vladimir putin first giving his press
conference later joe biden doing his own
press conference and both taking
questions from the media
i want to focus in on the putin press
conference today because vladimir putin
was actually
very strongly confronted by reporters
but putin is so good at just slipping
around
answering any questions that he ends up
saying
really nothing even when asked directly
about the deaths of his political
opponents
the fact that dissidents end up poisoned
in russia so let's dive right in
here he's asked if he'll stop the cyber
attacks and stop the crackdowns on his
opposition
see if you can find an answer here and
thank you very much for
giving me this question uh first of all
could you characterize the dynamic
between yourself and president biden was
it hostile or was it friendly
and secondly throughout these
conversations did you commit
to ceasing carrying out cyber attacks on
the united states did you commit
to stopping threatening ukraine's
security and did you commit to stop
cracking down on the opposition in
russia
the um first overall evaluation
as far as that is concerned i don't
think there was any kind of hostility on
the contrary
our meeting was obviously
a fundamental one many of our joint
positions
are divergent but nevertheless i think
that both sides
manifested determination to
try and understand each other and try
and converge our positions
and i think it was very constructive as
far as
cyber security is concerned we agreed
that we would begin
consultations on that issue and i
believe that's extraordinary
just no answer and and putin is really
amazing at this quite frankly
asked about the treatment of dissident
alexei navalny putin does two things
that he often does these are classics
from the putin playbook
one putin won't say the guy's name
he'll refer to him as the person you
mentioned or the gentleman you're in
question
and he says simply well the guy was
breaking the law
as far as our
non-systematic or non-standard
opposition is concerned and the
gentleman you quoted first of all
this man knew that he was
breaking the law of russia
he is somebody who has been twice
convicted and he consciously
ign ignored the requirements of the law
uh the gentleman in question went abroad
for treatment
uh his registration was not asked for
the gentleman you referenced this is a
classic putin move
and of course being suspected of
breaking the law
even if true doesn't justify in many
countries it doesn't justify or lead to
the treatment that alexei navalny has
received now guys this doesn't mean the
u.s doesn't do bad things
this doesn't mean the u.s doesn't have
inhumane jails and prisons
but it's just our analysis of of what it
is that is happening in russia
and how it is that putin responds to
questions about it an
abc reporter is called upon for a
question
and says to putin the list of your
political opponents who are dead
imprisoned or jailed is long
what are you afraid of and putin either
doesn't understand the question or more
likely
putin's a very smart guy putin pretends
not to understand
and successfully avoids actually
answering americans abc news
american colleagues
mr president thank you so much for
taking my question
president biden has said that he would
respond if cyber attacks from russia do
not
stop i'm curious what did he tell you
did he make any threats and a quick
follow-up if i may sir
the list of your political opponents who
are dead prisoned or jailed
is long alexis navalny this organization
calls for free
and fair elections an end to corruption
but russia has
outlawed that organization calling it
extremists and you have now prevented
anyone who supports him to run for
office
so my question is mr president what are
you so afraid of
you should assure us right well once
again
i would like to repeat
uh what i said about uh so-called
foreign agents and
the people
say that they are part of the
unauthorized opposition
i've already spoken to your colleagues
now i have to repeat that to you
uh okay once again the us has
passed a law which said that
the us would uh particularly favor
individual organizations in russia so it
just goes nowhere
and the reporter points out you didn't
answer the question
what about those dead political
opponents in russia
and putin still will not answer
you didn't answer my question sir if all
of your political opponents
are dead in prison poison
doesn't that send a message that you do
not want a fair political fight
people rioted and went into the congress
in the us with political demands and
many people were dictated as criminals
and
they are threatened with imprisonment
from 20 to 25 years
and these people were immediately
arrested after those events he's called
out
and he just brings up the january 6th
trump riots and again for people who say
david you're too aggressive about putin
i'm praising putin
you've really got to hand it to the guy
he doesn't get phased by being called
out
for the political murders that he's
suspected of being involved in
or having ordered last one putin asked
about his relationship with the west and
how
russian politics is seen as unstable
putin answers about everything other
than that take a look at this
bbc news
predictable relations but the
west thinks that unpredictability
is a hallmark of russian politics
how do you think you can improve
relations with the west
well i think you've really got to a
high-level art there i envy
the first part of your question
the west considers and are you going to
reject that you say
allow me first of all to answer the
first part of your question
you said that in russia uh russian
foreign policy
is unpredictable allow me
to respond first of all with a couple of
facts what about the withdrawal of the
us
uh from the uh adm treaty
uh absolutely unpredictable that was so
i'm going to stop it there because it it
just goes nowhere
putin has this ability to talk and talk
and talk and say nothing that is really
stunning
and um it it i i wonder
does he do this with biden in other
words during the summit did the summit
end early maybe
we don't know why it ended early i think
a lot of it was sort of like what else
are we going to talk about
did the summit end early because putin
was doing this stuff it's just an
incredible filibustering and so
really um unsurprising
but amazing how putin is just able to do
this and do this and do this and as a
reminder
i don't want war with russia i don't see
russia as a unique
enemy but i don't play koi with
authoritarian
types and i find nothing progressive in
it and
me as a progressive social democrat
i find things to criticize about the
united states
i'm against american imperialism around
the world
on and on and on and also i see very
little that is redeeming
about governments that function the way
that putin's russia functions but i
don't want war with russia
guys don't email me saying i'm uh uh
suggesting or implying that we need to
uh attack russia because i'm not
and if you believe that i would
challenge you to find even one instance
of me saying so
i want to do another segment on the
recent leak of tax information about
american billionaires that was leaked by
propublica recently
because i am seeing a ton of people
seemingly misunderstanding the
significance of the story
pro-publica leaked the taxes of some of
the wealthiest people in the united
states and they came up with something
they're calling the true tax rate now
the true tax rate is an interesting
metric but it's important to understand
that the true tax rate is not something
that is related to tax
law um the true tax rate as called by
propublica relates to
how much did you pay in taxes relative
to how much your net worth
went up and that includes something we
call unrealized gains in the united
states
this may not be something anybody cares
about but i think this is a really
important detail to understand
the true tax rate that propublica came
up with
is based on on a an idea that is not how
we tax people in the united states in
the u.s
we tax people from an income and capital
gains standpoint
on realized gains in just about every
situation
if your stock portfolio doubles but you
don't sell any stock
you don't pay taxes on those gains
because you've not realized
those gains now what is an exception to
that and it's an important exception is
property taxes on on real estate
in property taxes there's something
called the assessed value
of your property so if you own a
property and you buy it and it's
assessed by your city
as being worth four hundred thousand
dollars you pay a yearly property tax
on four hundred thousand dollars of
value now if in the next year
the value of the property goes up to
five hundred thousand
and the city comes by and reassesses
your property at five hundred thousand
dollars even though you didn't sell the
property in a sense you didn't realize
the gains
you immediately pay more taxes that is
an exception in the united states
but generally speaking in the us
we do not pay taxes on unrealized gains
we don't have that for stocks we don't
have that
for bonds if people want that you have
to lobby for it
so i think that the propublica article
was very interesting not because
warren buffett is doing anything wrong
or illegal by not paying taxes on
unrealized stock market gains that's not
warren buffett's doing
it's not even really a loophole it's the
way the system is designed it's not even
you're not really
circumventing the letter nor the spirit
of the law
in the united states as if we didn't
know it we have a system
that favors people who earn money from
assets
rather than who earn money from labor
when you go out and work
and you get paid a salary or an hourly
wage you are realizing those gains
immediately
as far as the tax code is concerned you
took your labor
you went to work for a week you sold
your labor and you got money
you've realized the gains on the sale of
your labor and now
you immediately pay taxes we call that
income taxes
on the contrary when i uh when my tesla
stock right
doubled and tripled and quadrupled and
quintupled right it went crazy
i didn't pay any taxes on it until i
panic sold half of it stupidly
because i thought elon musk was uh uh uh
going to be absolutely destroyed for
smoking pot with joe rogan and saying i
might take the company private or
whatever it was
so i panic sold half of my stock i
realized the gains and then i paid
taxes on it that's the way things work
so the
important takeaway for me from the pro
publica story is
if you want to change that you have to
change the reality of how the tax system
works and there's a misunderstanding
about it in the sense that the true tax
rate
as described by propublica it's not a
real thing
and none of the billionaires are
breaking the law we just have a system
where you pay taxes on realized gains
and wages
now there's also a different take on the
story that is pretty funny
i came across this yesterday when
researching my segment on the online
left
i mentioned that the hills show or
channel
rising has new hosts i found out about
this a couple days ago
the one clip i saw i'm not even going to
play it because i don't want to give it
any attention
the one clip i saw the two new hosts who
i guess
it's the idea that you've got a left and
a right-wing host now still on the hill
um they were agreeing the issue with the
pro-publica story is that the tax
information leaked at all
guys that is not it you know we can talk
about these are private citizens there's
a discussion to have about obtaining and
leaking people's taxes
but the big hot take on this story from
hosts supposedly on the left and right
is how did we even learn about this
stuff and that's really wrong
they sound like the people who after
edward snowden
exposed all of these bulk surveillance
techniques
that are extremely oppressive in terms
of the violation of privacy
and really do very little to prevent
terrorism there were a couple
people after that who were saying i
can't believe
that this was made public and that now
we know about it we need to focus on how
it was made public give me a break guys
that is not the story here
but there is a real story here and it's
an interesting one and it is again just
the reminder that in the us
we have a system that heavily favors
making money from assets
rather than making money from working
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription when you go
to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video i would
really love it if you grabbed yourself a
membership on my website at
joinpackman.com the number one way to
support our show we
do an extra show every single day i'm
joined by producer pat daly and we do an
extra show
for our members and it's an
award-winning show
it really is although we've given out
all of the awards and you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
coupon code available better21 feel free
to pay full price but feel free to take
the discount as well
our the david pakman show subreddit is
now
uh it's amazing what's going on over 31
000 of our viewers are now subscribed
for free at davidpakman.com
reddit i want to look at a few posts i
saw this morning user jp dinsies posted
in response to our segment about
apparently marjorie
taylor green the republican
congresswoman just learning that the
holocaust was really bad
j.p dinzie's posts yeah people are just
as
or even dumber than marjorie taylor
green on the holocaust writing
me and david are both jewish so we
learned pretty extensively about the
holocaust and the reasons it happened
but very few other people really know
what it was or how it happened some
people think all the jews were
just putting gas chambers some think it
was only jews in germany that were
attacked
in a recent poll 25 percent of young new
yorkers
believe jews caused the holocaust now i
looked that study up it's actually 20
of young new yorkers but that's true 20
percent
of young new yorkers believed that the
jews caused or were responsible for
the holocaust and the point here is
that um jp dinzie's
says my shock at how uninformed
green was and probably still is about
the holocaust
is actually not that rare her her lack
of knowledge about the holocaust
is not that unusual if that's true
that's extraordinarily disturbing
uh i'm not saying that that it's it's
untrue it actually
very well may be true um one of the
things i've learned in doing this show
is if you overestimate the intelligence
of the american people
you are often disappointed and that's
really how we got trump
uh many people said that there's not
enough
stupid people in this country that
they're gonna elect trump and then
the republican uh primary voters chose
him and then uh so
so did the american people so yeah i i
think
the the big lesson from doing this show
is
do not overestimate the intelligence of
the american people
another post about yet another
airline flight rerouted this one
from or to san francisco rerouted
because of an argument
over elbow placement on arm rests and
listen elbow placement on arm rests is a
conflict
uh you have to figure out do you share
someone gets the front of the armrest
and someone gets the back or whatever
the airline uh you know it's not uh
road rage it's air rage it is crazy what
is going on i have a bunch of flights
coming up i am going to do everything i
can and
this is my commitment to you right now
i'm going to do everything i can to
avoid getting involved in any such
incident
um yeah let's see if i succeed and then
lastly
i love this we had a call on monday from
a horrible anti-semitic
military veteran and uh reddit user
baron steuben posted
progressive veterans don't let people
like the one in the voicemail or the
traders on january 6th
give veterans a bad name plenty of us
are proud progressives
who want to mail help make this country
better for everyone
organizations like common defense and
vote vets embody this goal
and should be in the public eye more i
am very much aware of that we have a lot
of uh progressive veterans in our
audience uh
more veterans voted for joe biden the
democratic candidate
in the last election than have voted for
any democratic candidate in a long time
i don't falsely believe that veterans
are this uh
conservative monolith there are many
conservatives in the military
just like in law enforcement but there
are plenty of progressive veterans
and uh appreciate the message of support
you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit yesterday i briefly talked about
this on our live stream
um tucker carlson fox news propagandist
is now increasingly signal boosting
a uh baseless and wild conspiracy
that fbi agents were behind
in terms of planning or even
participants in
the january 6th trump riots and
we're going to look at a couple clips of
this starting with tucker carlson
two days ago listen to him
lay this out let's take a look but
strangely some of the key people who
participated on january 6th
have not been charged right look at the
documents the government calls those
people
unindicted co-conspirators what does
that mean well it means that in
potentially every single case they were
fbi operatives
understand the language there tucker
says it means that
potentially in every single case they
were fbi operatives
this is baseless this is baseless he's
not saying i have any evidence
that fbi operatives planned the january
6 riots or participated in them
we know about the issue of off-duty law
enforcement
participating um in in the riots we know
about the issue
of current and former military being
over-represented in the riots but
tucker is alleging something else i'm
going to be honest i don't think tucker
believes this i think tucker is doing it
because you know he knows his audience
is gonna eat it up take a listen to what
else he says
really in the capital on january 6th
right
for example one of those unindicted
co-conspirators is someone government
documents identify only as person two
according to those documents person two
stayed in the same hotel room as a man
called thomas caldwell an
insurrectionist
a man alleged to be a member of the
group the oath keepers
person two also quotes stormed the
barricades at the capitol on january 6th
understand that there are countless
reasons
why in this court document
some other co-conspirators would be
referred to as person two
or person three including that they
are not if you look at person two's
court documents if there are such
documents
the people in this case might be
referred to as person one two three four
whatever
there could be other reasons to maintain
the privacy of those individuals
they may not yet have been charged
because the cases are still being built
but none of that signals any reason to
believe that they are
fbi agents alongside thomas caldwell
yeah
the government's indictments further
indicate that caldwell who by the way is
a 65 year old man
yes dangerous insurrectionist was led to
believe there would be a
quick reaction force also participating
on january 6th
that quick reaction force caldwell was
told would be led by someone called
person 3 who had a hotel room and an
accomplice with them
now understand that when it's convenient
and they do this all the time when it's
convenient
uh tucker and others will cite the
insurrectionists
and not even question their credibility
but in
other times when it's not convenient
they will immediately say you can't
trust these insurrectionist writers
first of all they're accused of crime so
they'll say anything they can to get out
of trouble
here because tucker is ginning up
another one of these
furious conspiracies for his audience
these
very same uh defendants are completely
trustworthy in what they say
but wait here's the interesting thing
yeah person two
and person three were organizers of the
riot
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
so fbi remember there is no evidence of
that that he has presented
none you have to know how to listen to
what he there is no evidence of it
we're organizing the attack on the
capitol there's no evidence on january
6th according to government documents
no so now he's being tricky now he's
saying
the individuals we are not naming in the
documents were organizers
but tucker is the one saying they were
fbi agents and tucker is now building on
the first minute of this segment as
evidence for the second minute
and those two are not alone in all
revolver news reported there are quote
upwards of 20
unindicted co-conspirators in the oath
keeper indictments
all playing various roles in the
conspiracy who have not been charged for
virtually the exact
same activities and in some cases much
much more severe activities
as those named alongside them in the
indictments so understand that first of
all
revolver news is a right-wing media
outlet
of questionable credibility number two
still
no evidence presented that these are
folks from the fbi so then the next day
tucker doubles down and actually brings
on darren beatty from revolver news
and again it's this is how you
propagandize
to ignorant people if congress because
they oppose the regime
even vladimir putin's not doing that and
there's a former assistant director of
the fbi
calling for it on television and no one
noticed so
we're rounding people up how about
rounding up the fbi operatives that
rioted on january 6th when
so now he is without evidence just
assuming this from his previous segment
it's it's
and remember no evidence has been
presented don't identify the guy who
shot ashley babbitt to death
this is crazy and we should resist it
darren beatty heads up revolver news
here we go glad to see him tonight
darren thanks so much
for coming on it sounds like according
to this
i have to say remarkable piece that
you've just put up late last night at
midnight
that the fbi was organizing
the riots of january 6. so to tucker it
sounds that way because of this article
now the guy who wrote the article is
here let's listen
well yes it certainly suggests that
possibility and i'm hearing from
it suggests the possibility
i don't even know that we need to listen
to more it suggests the possibility this
is
all a house of cards with no evidence
people that this is the most important
and the darkest
investigative piece they've seen in
years but the american people the people
who support revolver news are the ones
telling darren beatty that so i
we don't even need to go further and you
you guys if you know me
the fbi is not uniquely good or uniquely
bad
intelligence agencies in the united
states and in other countries
sometimes do things we would call good
and sometimes do things that we call bad
it is not about that it is not about we
now love the fbi we now love the cia
it's this is all based on
nothing tucker's story is based on
darren beatty's story
and darren beatty shows up and says well
there is the suggestion
that it is possible that fbi agents
might have actually been the organizers
of the january 6 riots if you have
evidence i want to see it and bring it
to me and i will be the first to say
look we have evidence of that
no evidence this is now going on
multiple nights on fox news
and not a shred of evidence has actually
been presented
we'll have more on this on the show
instagram page follow us on instagram at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming
a member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro
khanna who represents california's 17th
district located in the heart of silicon
valley
uh congressman always great to speak
with you always a pleasure david
so there's so many things to talk about
let's start with
the united states innovation and
competition act of 2021
formerly known as the endless frontier
act
what uh what what's the the goal here
what would this legislation do
first of all would be a dramatic
increase in science and technology
funding
of the kind we haven't seen since the
apollo years we're at about 0.7 percent
of gdp
in science research comparatively china
has almost doubled 1.3 percent of their
gdp
this would add 250 billion
over 100 billion of that in science and
technology development
and it would put this across the country
so
focusing on black communities brown
communities rural communities
making sure innovation is accessible to
places left behind
when we look at something like that bill
and we look at um the infrastructure
proposal
and we look at all of these different
big pieces of legislation that that
could be tackled
and we run into the inevitable questions
about
okay in the senate does it need 60 votes
and if not can it be done with 50 but if
it can be done with the 50
do democrats have 50 or do they have 49
or 48
is this just going to be the question
around every piece of legislation for
the foreseeable future
it is and look unfortunately we're
living in a senate which is 50 50. we
thought we would do better we didn't uh
we need to do
build on that majority and we're living
in a house that only has a five vote
majority so
it is the challenge of governing with
slim majorities and it's the challenge
of governing with a
uh dis uh dysfunctional senate which has
a
filibuster rule that uh allows the
minority
uh a legitimizes obstruction
i don't think you and i have talked
about this i mean in terms of the
filibuster
there are some who say just eliminate it
period eliminate it altogether and then
those who say but that's also a
double-edged sword
there's these intermediate ideas of well
instead of saying
you need you need 60 to end debate
make it that you need 40 actual people
to continue pushing it forward and kind
of like flip the onus around or require
it to be a talking filibuster
what what's your view about this issue
my view is that we just need to end the
filibuster and it all together been used
over and over again to suppress and
obstruct civil rights legislation racial
equality legislation in fact that's been
its
primary use and it was a invention of
calhoun who wanted to give
slave states the power to block
progressive legislation
but i'm for anything that will advance
the ball so if we're going to say
okay we want to have voting rights be an
exception to the filibuster
for that if we're going to put the onus
on senators to actually
speak and show up and that's going to
make it much harder to filibuster on for
that
but ultimately we need to do away with
this it's not part of our
constitution it's not part of our
founder's vision do you worry about the
argument that is that it's a
double-edged sword and it could really
come back and hurt democrats when the
political circumstances and the division
are just slightly different
for two reasons i don't first the
republicans push
their agenda through anyway that's how
they got the donald trump tax cut so
a lot of the republican agenda let's cut
taxes let's slash
government isn't subject to the
filibuster it's a
lot of our policies that are subject to
the filibuster second
in a country i think our problem is that
our politics is too slow
our change is too hard uh i worry less
between us zigzagging from
uh one place to another then i worry
about institutional
uh roadblocks and gridlock in our
inability to do things
when you think about uh what any of the
bills that you're
currently supporting um and that
includes usica
and all of these other things that we're
talking about infrastructure etc
we had this propublica story a couple of
weeks ago
where they identified that relative to
the growth of net worth which as i've
explained to my audience that's not how
we tax in the united states we tax on
realized gains
but it exposed that there are if you're
making money from assets rather than
labor
you can until you realize those gains
have significant
tax-free growth of of one's net worth
do you think that in the context of any
bill that's designed
to help workers that we also need to be
revisiting
how we tax assets versus labor
yes we need a wealth tax in this country
i mean think about this david my
district
uh has 10 trillion dollars a market
value in the bay area
right companies it's grown 35 in the bay
area 10 trillion dollars
we ought to be taxing some of that and a
lot of those billionaires frankly would
pay the
tax they won't oppose it instead this
bipartisan bill for infrastructure is
going to fund it
by raising the gas tax on to the index
of inflation
so we're going to tax the working class
who basically have to drive 40 minutes
because they can't afford an apartment
in san francisco or in new york
so they are commuting as is and we're
going to put the burden
on them to pay for infrastructure
instead of on the tech
billionaires and the multi-billionaires
who produced all this wealth it makes no
sense
so i don't know about you i see an
actual tax on wealth
as so unlikely to pass in the next four
years
that i i wonder how much it's even worth
talking about it
but some of the biden proposals
on either capital gains or you know
there's other ideas that maybe are more
politically feasible how
important do you think it is as someone
who's been advocating for the wealth tax
and other things that quite frankly i
think are unlikely to pass anytime soon
how much is the balance in your mind
between
trying to get something done that can
actually be done versus
talking about what you see as the gold
standard
well i think we could do both david i
mean tom swazi who's a moderate on ways
and means and brendan boyle have
actually come out now
for a while tax at one time well tech's
not like warren two percent every year
but they said
let's call it the patriot tax with the
pandemic
all this wealth that was generated let's
tax at one time so
that is because of people like you and
elizabeth warren and others who have
put the idea into the public discourse
and what often happens is it takes
years and then finally something happens
so we need to continue to do that
but we can't let the perfect be the
enemy of the good and if we can get some
solid reforms now such as a step up in
basis means if you buy a million dollars
of facebook
stock you hold it till the end of your
life if you want to have kids and you
give it to your kids
they should have to pay tax on the
capital gains right now they don't
have to literally you can die with uh
capital gains never having been taxed
and pass it on to your ears
fighting closes that gap and it raises
billions of dollars
uh we ought to be increasing the tax on
corporations
so let's get those done but ultimately
if you really want to fund things in
this country we need a
a wall street financial tax we need a
wealth tax
and i don't think that will hurt
innovation or economic growth but it
would fund
the basic infrastructure based on the
people who have made
fortunes inconceivable fortunes yeah
there's some pretty slick stuff and by
i don't know if by slick i i even mean
this sarcastically or not i mean it's
interesting to me that this can be done
one can even to build on the idea of the
stepped
up basis one can even borrow against
their portfolio
and in a sense de facto realize the
gains like you can actually get access
to
that growth without even having to pay
the capital gains
and pass it on tax free i mean that
that's quite a mechanism that exists in
the united states tax code
it is and david and and trust me that
it's all being used by these
billionaires or hiring lawyers and you
know in one sense you can't
blame them i mean that you're they're
taking advantage of rules that congress
has written so
yeah they could be more patriotic
perhaps a pay tax but how many people
are going to say yeah i want to pay more
tax than i owe
right so what we really need to do is
change the rules make sure that
these billionaires who produce all this
wealth are being taxed fairly on it
and i i don't think a billionaire
sitting there is going to think okay
maybe i shouldn't
or an aspiring billionaire i'm not going
to start the next google
uh because the government may take two
percent of my net worth that's just not
how entrepreneurs think
how do you see the sort of tiering of
priorities when it comes to the
financial stuff and what i mean by that
is
sometimes i talk to people who are on
the left who i think feel pressure to
say
basically once you're making a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year or even
five hundred thousand dollars a year
that and making 10 million and a hundred
million and a billion
it should really be seen in the same the
same way you're just making a ton of
money and
when i actually get into it with a lot
of people
we sort of get to realize that you know
there's a big difference between making
350k with a couple kids in a big city
versus people who are making 550 and 500
million dollars a year how
important do you think it is to approach
those groups
differently versus just wrap everybody
together
it's very important to approach them
differently because the real taxes have
to be on the ultra rich and the big
corporations and
that's where the real money is uh and
you know tax the people who are making
billions of dollars some of it perhaps
legitimately look they may have come up
with a great idea they see the digital
revolution
sure they understand it's transforming
an industry they're at the forefront of
leading that
great celebrate it but then they have to
pay a tax
so that society can transition but
that's where the real taxes don't go
after the person
who's making a few hundred thousand uh
it already
uh has a couple kids in college in the
suburbs i mean
look make sure it goes up to 39 but
that's not you don't want to stop
the the middle class or even the upper
middle class you want to do is say
we've got we're going to prioritize the
working class we're going to look out
for the middle class and upper middle
class but we're really going to get the
revenue
from the big corporations and the ultra
rich and i think
maybe this is something that the truly
ultra rich really benefit from which is
that
when they are sort of wrapped in
together
with folks that are wealthy but less
wealthy
they are maybe better able to take
advantage of the tax law
and end up paying as an effective tax
rate even less like the
ultra rich often end up paying slightly
less
than the very rich to distinguish
between two very rich groups
that may be is something that would
deserve some significant attention
absolutely i think we have to treat the
ultra rich as a separate class given the
wealth generation in this country and i
i think taxing them more in my view uh
is in their interest and this is why
there's some
so many billionaires by the way in my
district who are fine with the wall tax
and the reason it's in their interest is
because if you want to prevent
a resentment a hostility to wealth
generation
and a lot of their wealth generation in
my view has come through honest
hard work creativity and ingenuity it's
not that they deserve
all of the billions there are lots of
people that went into it but it's not
that they were just
you know lucky they did work hard and
but if you want people to celebrate that
then pay the tax and show that you're
generating that wealth is helping
society when you don't pay that tax
that's where you have the resentment uh
last thing i wanted to um
ask you about in in terms of budget
reconciliation
where would you like to see it used in
order to get
one more big accomplishment in 2021
climate clearly it has to uh have
climate in it i mean the infrastructure
plan that currently is on the table
uh is basically a version of what trump
had it has none of the climate gold so
we need the climate goals in there
uh we need a a broader vision on tax
policy
so that you don't have the working class
hit with the tax policy
that would be my my essential part i
mean obviously i want to expand medicare
i want prescription drugs i have
a whole a child care a whole vision but
if
if the white house were to call me and
said what are the must-haves
i'd say good tax policy and climate do
you agree
that for democrats to make a solid case
for 2022
which really is going to kick off i mean
it might be january
it really might even be november
december some consultants are saying
do you think that joe biden needs one
more major accomplishment in addition to
vaccine rollout and coveted stimulus
this calendar year
i do and i think he'll get one but the
question is what kind will it be if it
is just a bipartisan infrastructure bill
that may help and it may help in
moderate swing districts but i i don't
think it's going to mobilize our base
and we need both we need
something for the independent swing love
voters but we also need to show our base
that we really delivered on progressive
change so i would
say he needs one big thing that uh
appeals to the base as well yeah a uh a
relatively small infrastructure bill
that mitt romney loves i don't know if
that's necessarily going to count as the
progressive change people are people are
waiting for
completely agree with you um we've been
speaking with congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
always great having you on david always
enjoy it thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch
including hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
alright so yesterday after the big biden
putin summit former president donald
trump appeared on sean hannity's fox
news
program to deliver i guess what was
billed as analysis of joe biden's
meeting
with the russian president vladimir
putin that we talked about earlier it
took place in geneva switzerland
and it was really pathetic and in some
sense it was almost kind of sad
a trump desperate for relevance
relegated to opining about how the guy
who defeated him easily
did during a summit with a guy vladimir
putin
who walked all over donald trump during
trump's presidency now
whoa hold on a second everybody take it
easy i'm not saying trump and putin
ever got together to plan anything i'm
not saying i want a war with russia
i don't i just i've got to be clear
because otherwise that
sort of putin loving segment of the
audience
will come after me but let's check out
some of these clips
and trump is just so jealous of joe
biden
and the fact that biden just kind of
behaved normally during the summit like
the summit was no big
success other than it was a normal
summit
and it was a return to kind of standard
diplomacy and the interview with hannity
very quickly went completely
off the rails uh trump now just this
isn't even related to putin
trump just doing openly anti-vaxxed
talking points now listen to this
now we have to get back and the schools
have to get open and frankly uh
we're lucky we have the vaccine but the
vaccine on very young people is
something that you gotta really stop you
have to get
back to running your country i mean what
is he talking about
schools basically are open and it's also
summer for
some school districts already and
everybody's going to be back in the fall
most schools already opened and vaccines
on young people
we have to stop vaccines on young people
we haven't even started vaccines on
young people
pfizer is approved for 12 plus otherwise
there's nothing else we're starting to
test the vaccine now
we're testing it safely it appears to be
very safe these are just straight-up
anti-vaxx talking points now from trump
who by the way wants credit for the
vaccine
which is really dangerous for children
even though there's not actually
evidence of that
see reasons and i am a big believer in
what we did with the vex
it's incredible what we did trump is the
winner for doing the vaccine
but it's a very dangerous one for
children and we've got to stop giving it
to them
which we're not yet until it's tested
and appears safe
you see the results but to have every
school child
where it's 99.99
they just don't you know they're just
not affected or affected badly
having to receive a vaccine i think is
something that you should of course
nobody has to receive it unless you
eventually if it becomes a requirement
to go to school
as has been the case for other vaccines
the parents would get to choose
i want my kid in this school and so i
will do the required vaccinations
to attend of which if covet 19 is added
would not be the only vaccine or you can
opt not to go there but nobody is being
forced to vaccinate we don't have to
stop vaccines on kids because we haven't
even started them yet it's
it's all wild in this next clip hannity
cuts trump off
when he starts a completely unhinged
rant about
wind turbines again they're making
windmills all over the place to ruin our
land and kill our birds
to kill everything windmills are killing
everything guys
the the windmills that they're killing
everything not gonna be and they're very
intermittent as you learn from
watching over the last four months it's
intermittent energy
it's not good it's not going to power
our great factories
and it's real what did you make yeah
there was a question of what there was a
question of whether ukraine would join
nato and biden's answer oh man that is
just great hannity's like this is not
the the windmills killing everybody is
not a great direction to go in for
hannity's program so hannity tries to
derail that
then trump is still calling the 1918 flu
the 1917 flu
and if we weren't successful sean i'll
tell you this you would have another
1917
uh tragedy where almost 100 million
people died
yep still calling it that still calling
it the 1917 flu uh
trump then in the midst of this uh
wanting to go back to talk about hillary
and hannity is actually helping him do
it take a look at this
we know that hillary clinton paid for
the dirty russian misinformation dossier
that even christopher steele doesn't
stand by and
the sub source doesn't stand by right
and then it wasn't just hannity doing it
trump also
insisting on going back and talking
about
comey and mccabe and they they just will
not stop
and i'm talking about very very serious
things if you look at comey and mccabe
and the two lovers and all of the things
that went on
and they weren't prosecuted if you read
the horowitz report
and of course everyone's still waiting
for durham what happened to durham
how is that allowed to go into another
administration by the way is he in the
witness protection program
i'd like to know where he is too is he
in the witness protection program
really touching on the issues of the
dave remember trump invited on to
analyze as if trump could analyze
anything trump invited on to analyze
the uh putin biden summit
and doing anti-vaxx doing the 1917
flu doing what about peter strzok and
his lover
uh paige or whatever her name was uh
trump then
again completely delusional claiming
that an endorsement from
him is stronger than anything else
anybody could ever
even imagine so i'm very honored to say
that
my endorsement means more than any
endorsement that has ever been given by
anybody i mean
you know there i don't know exactly what
he's talking about trump
uh became president republicans then
lost the house
in 2018 lost the senate in 2020
and lost the white house in 2020 and
trump wants us to believe his
endorsements are really really strong
of course no trump interview is complete
until he again sort of references i
didn't really lose and i may be back
soon
here he is doing that you ever
considered it and are you considering it
well i am and frankly if you think of it
that's what i've been doing and talking
about for
a long time and i guess that's why we
got him by surprise in 16
and in 20 we did much better than we did
in 16 and
uh shockingly we were supposed to win
easily at 64 million votes and we got 75
million votes and
we didn't win but let's see what happens
on that the whole thing is
let's see because trump could be back
absolutely any day and still
still sort of floating that and
signaling his followers
and then lastly here um hannity throws a
complete softball to trump about
if you run in 2024 what will you do
differently and trump just he can't keep
it together he talks about the clintons
and fake investigations and all sorts of
wacky stuff
is there anything and we have a minute
left
if you do run in 2024 right what might
you do differently what do you know now
that you didn't know in 2016
well you know we ran a very successful
administration we had the greatest
economy in history we had 160 million
jobs we were never even close to that no
nobody was ever even close to that and
we did it twice because then we did it
after the pandemic we came with a
vaccine we did a lot of great things
and we did it after but i was under
siege with
fake investigations and everything and i
was doing this while i was under
siege from phony people with phony
russia russia russia that was caused by
the people were fake
that's that's interesting we've known he
thinks the investigations were fake but
the people doing them were fake too
clinton and the dnc democrats and
all of that and we did it we built space
force we did you know we did
we rebuilt the military we got the
largest tax cut in history the largest
regulation cuts in history
i'm pretty sure everything he's saying
is a lie
they weren't the biggest tax cuts in
history he did cut some regulations but
it
unfortunately he didn't cut that many
but not they were damaging the cuts but
i don't think anything he's saying here
is true nothing
none of it plus we did anwar which
they've already
excluded thanks to murkowski in alaska
and uh you know hannity rapping yeah so
i mean just an incredible incredible
bizarre interview
and my question continues to be can
anybody tell me specifically
what was the massive failure of the
biden europe trip that every right
winger is ranting about they say it was
a failure but they don't mention what
the failure was
they don't have anything specific to
mention they just want to create this
atmosphere that it was terrible
and then the fox viewers just repeat it
but
they never can explain what was the
failure and also
don't forget what happened in the putin
trump summit in helsinki
in july of 2018 where the the whole
question was is trump going to confront
putin
about russia's meddling in the 2016
election
and trump came out and when he was asked
about it said i hold
both countries responsible partially
blaming the us
if there was russian meddling which he
won't say there was
uh it's partially the us's fault and
then he also said listen putin denied it
putin denied it and he seemed sincere in
his denial
so everybody just runs around trump
trump met with kim jong-un and he
thought he got incredible concessions
from kim jong-un
didn't realize these are the concessions
that they always make and never stick to
trump thought it was a big victory
trump meets with putin and he says i
don't know putin he was pretty
convincing and it's like this is what
putin does this
putin is the slick guy trump wishes he
could be
and trump fell for that and it's just
all humiliating and embarrassing and joe
biden's not perfect or anything close to
it
but it is good to be beyond the insanity
of foreign policy under trump we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p here's a funny voicemail about
joe biden snapped at cnn reporter
caitlin collins yesterday and then later
apologized and it's funny because
trump never apologizes for anything this
this is a funny voicemail
hi dave did he biden apologizing to
caitlyn collins from cnn
man that makes him look so weak what a
sad old man to apologize
dave i'm totally kidding but listen um
is that nuts look i think he was dead
right but um
why do we make such a big deal about a
normal man apologizing for raising his
voice
oh it's crazy because we had such an
abnormal man in the white house
that that is exactly what's going on uh
donald trump would never apologize
for anything trump viciously attacked
people in the press
all the time he never apologized he
would always double down
um and i you know i i know that it's a
joke
the eggman is not really mad at joe
biden for apologizing
um i think that what the europe trip
really was notable for was how
remarkable normality felt
it was just sort of like a normal
meeting with other world leaders
did joe biden do everything that a
progressive would want him to
do and raise every issue no but it was
just a return to a semblance of
normality
at the end of the trip biden snapped at
a reporter
and then within 30 minutes he apologized
and said that that wasn't the right
thing to do
it's remarkable in how unremarkable it
all was
and we became very much unaccustomed to
that during the previous
four years we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about
congress approving a bill to make
juneteenth a federal holiday
we will talk about a baker being fined
for refusing to make
a trans transition cake transgender
transition cake
and we will also talk about the cruise
line
gambit in florida that republican
governor dan
ron desantis is doing all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss it get instant access by
becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman